hey seven and three on the year tyler
malley is coming off an outing against
the atlanta braves good hitting lineup
on the road the e.r.a just over two he's
been great sharp ground ball to bottom
pirouettes in the outfield
underhand shovel to maui get that right
release point and it's sometimes
difficult to hold on to
call strike three fastball buried at the
knees
and i think the cubs reaction to the
strike zone two days running tells us a
bit about where they are mentally and
emotionally
a fourth hitch walk
[Applause]
base hit
center field baez
on his way to third no he pulls up and
it's a good thing the tyler and equine
throw is pretty good
and the bases are low to second walk of
the inning
runners go swing into this
struck
you see the right-hander leans heavily
on that slider throws it 45 percent of
the time we'll mix and sinkers and four
seamers
he's ahead 1-2
on the fifth overall pick from florida
who bounces to baez
gets the ground ball out
shift was on well played
they get the out
quick eight pitch inning so when he
elevates puts that ball closer to you
the thought is that hey i can catch up
to that and that's not always the case
ortega works a full count and drives
this towards right field and that ball
is going to bounce off the wall
ortega in a second and will hold up
there
powell's ally will advance the runner
ortega to third and two down
[Applause]
pops out of the glove ortega is coming
home slides he's in there safe and the
cubs get a run
[Applause]
aboard the first red to reach today
[Applause]
what a play
what a reaction
alzheimer takes care of suarez
he's all right okay hopefully got a
little leather i don't think he's headed
right towards his ribs
comes with a one-nothing lead to start
the third here is chris bryant
well hit
up there out there
over there two nothing comes
well kb at his best back in may was very
aggressive attacking fastballs early and
doing damage
last night he had his first two hit game
since the end of may 3-1
contreras base hit left field
[Applause]
he's going to second base
he's in there
that's just good scouting a good heads
up aggressive base running and why not
take a risk with two outs jesse winker
does not have a great reputation
defensively although he has shown
improvement bigger lead in second one
two
bounced right side vado
low bound mali on the cover
through all his struggles still takes
his walks
third walk of the game
for maui who has five strikeouts to go
with that but the cubs get a man on
again
tapper beyond maui farmer shoots it one
play at first flips it there and best
ortega
grounded navado on a bent right knee
he'll take it himself
motto the only red to reach with his
base hit to begin the second
lefties
they want the ball down and they want
the ball in
dead center field for bottle back to the
wall god
a straight away shot for joey bottom
home run number 11.
red's on the board sprinted home 2-1
not necessarily in but down
and joey has shown
what his intent is when he walks up to
the plate is to hit the ball hard and do
some damage damage done
base hit
back to back
a homer followed by a single
and the cubs have the leadoff man on
here in the fifth
gets away
safely in the second
is bryant
grounded to short flip to second tag
drop lead man gone chris bryant
he started toward third base and farmer
knew he had him before the ball fit his
glove one two swing gonna miss down on
strikes rizzo
in the dirt that's a walk
one-two again swing and a miss he struck
him out
seven k's for mali
and he strands a couple of runners
tyler naked is fly to left and see if
they can mount a rally
against a largely dominant advert out
zolai who has struck out four walked
none
two outs in the air and he hammers that
one to right field tyler naquin ties the
game
way up the sun deck home run number 13
at 109 off the back
well lefties like the ball down and they
like it in
[Applause]
about a third do up for the cubs and
they'll face sean doolittle
do a little dispatches of wisdom foul
tips strike three
and there's the breaking ball from
doolittle
[Applause]
bouncer vado
will flip
and this is dual goes through his hands
and peterson will reach
ryan hendricks replaces sean doolittle
[Applause]
toward right it'll
drop peterson
on his way to third and
the throw
rolls through he's safely in there
grounded nevada leaping snare flip to
second one farmer on
[Applause]
dynamite double play
[Applause]
payoff
down and then bottles on once more
single homer
lead off wall
[Applause]
first pitch hammered to right hayward
back it skips to the fence
rips through second hayward now gathers
throw in
stop at third
and a double standing for stevenson the
reds cooking with gas second and third
nobody out
well no
suarez in the right field hayward odd
won't get there follow scores
hey eugenio suarez the go ahead ribby
single 3-2 reds
this could be two
there's one there's two well done
how's a lot a little fish pump there
[Applause]
swinging a miss out in front
deadly off speed two down
two two
frozen strike three
had two saves on his career chris
entering this season he looks first
third of the campaign in his second in
his many days
payoff
strike three called
off the glove of henry sogard hustling
and he'll make it
2-2
swing in the miss he struck him out
the reds and out away
high in the air down the line bottle
curling in foul ground bombo
makes the catch tumbling on his backside
and the reds guarantee the series as
they nip the cubs three to two